الدكتور مصطفى الباروتي هو رئيس
المبادرة الوطنية الفلسطينية
وعضو في البرلمان الفلسطيني وهو
ينضم إلي الآن من رالا في الضفة الغربية.
الدكتور الباروتي يقدر حقًا تخصيصك
الوقت للتحدث إلينا كنت أتساءل عما
إذا كان بإمكاني البدء أولاً بـ
الأخبار العاجلة التي وصلتنا خلال
الساعة والنصف الماضية أو نحو ذلك قادمة من
البيت الأبيض مفادها أن إسرائيل ستبدأ في
تنفيذ وقفات تكتيكية مدتها 4 ساعات في
شمال غزة كما
سمعناها للسماح للمواطنين أه  اهرب
والسماح بالمساعدة الإنسانية في
رد فعلك
سيدي لا أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى مواقف فقط
نحتاج إلى وقف إطلاق النار أه هذه الأوضاع تعني فقط
أنهم يقولون للناس لن
تقتل الآن ولكن بعد 4 ساعات من الآن
والرئيسي  هدف إسرائيل
فعلا هو التطهير العرقي للناس
من شمال غزة ومدينة
غزة أه لكن إذا تحركوا جنوبا سيتم
قصفهم أيضا في الجنوب 49% من
الفلسطينيين قتلوا معظمهم من المدنيين
قتلوا في الجنوب الجنوب لذلك أه أنا
لا أرى أي أمل فيما يحدث
إلا إذا كان هناك وقف كامل وشامل
لإطلاق النار وأقول إن أي حكومة
في العالم لا تؤيد وقف
إطلاق النار الفوري تصبح مشاركة وداعمة
لجرائم الحرب المستمرة التي تحدث في غزة
والتطهير العرقي والتهجير والتهجير.  أه والإبادة
الجماعية التي تحدث ضد الشعب الفلسطيني بما في ذلك بالطبع العقاب الجماعي
كيف تقرأون إذن الرد الأمريكي
لأن أمريكا لا تدعو إلى
وقف إطلاق النار أمريكا تدعو إلى
وقف ما هذا لا يكفي هل هم
جزء من هذه
الولايات المتحدة نعم الولايات المتحدة
تدعم إسرائيل بشكل كامل ولا
تتخذ حتى موقفا محايدا وفي هذه
الحالة لسوء الحظ
تواصل الولايات المتحدة دعم ما تريده إسرائيل
وما لا نريد رؤيته هو
استمرار  التطهير العرقي
لشمال غزة وكذلك مدينة
غزة وسمعت حجتهم يا سيد
الباروتي سمعت حجتهم
من الولايات المتحدة ومن
الإسرائيليين أن وقف إطلاق النار لن يؤدي إلا إلى
تقوية أه حماس ومنحهم الوقت
ل  أعد تجميع صفوفك، ماذا تقول لذلك
أعتقد أن إسرائيل لا تهاجم حماس فقط، بل
إنها تهاجم جميع الفلسطينيين،
حماس لا تحكم الضفة الغربية، فما
هو العذر لقتل 18
فلسطينيًا اليوم في الضفة الغربية، 14
في مخيم واحد للاجئين في جنين وأربعة؟
وفي أجزاء أخرى من
الضفة الغربية هاجموا الخليل وهاجموا بيت لحم وهاجموا
رامالا وهاجموا
جانين وهاجموا في كل مكان
كل جندي إسرائيلي وكل
شرطي إسرائيلي وكل مستوطن إسرائيلي غير شرعي
يشعر الآن أن لديه ترخيصًا
لقتل الفلسطينيين هذا الصباح
المستوطنين الإسرائيليين  هاجموا
مجتمعًا فلسطينيًا آخر في الشمال
وأخلوه بالكامل، لذا فقد قاموا
بالفعل بتهجير 35
مجتمعًا في الضفة الغربية، وما
يفعلونه هو أيضًا عمل من أعمال
التطهير العرقي في الضفة الغربية